l'institut médico pédagogique de saint
louis de la fondation père favron
accueille des enfants qui présentent des
troubles psychiques parfois accompagnées
de troubles moteurs ils sont suivis par
une professeure des écoles et une équipe
médico social ensemble ils proposent un
enseignement adapté à chacun des enfants
pour animer l'enseignement les
éducateurs propose régulièrement des
activités ludiques objectif apprendre et
évoluer globalement tout en s'amusant
ici il ya des sports collectifs pour
février ont fait beaucoup de l'activité
sportive ludique
qui tous les ans on retrouve à un
attrait déjà c'est la première base et
pour leur permettre sans rencontre de
phase d'apprentissage aujourd'hui
l'activité proposée et le cirque
lauranne psychomotricienne accompagné de
stéphane étudiants stagiaires
regarderont de près les difficultés et
les évolutions de chacun des enfants
que je vois ici à l'ump la plupart sont
accueillis pour une déficience
intellectuelle mais il faut savoir
qu'ils ont des troubles moteurs associés
psychomoteur du coup l'activité cirque
c'est des exercices qu'ils ont pas
l'habitude de faire du coup ça va mettre
en jeu le corps d'une nouvelle manière
donc ils vont vivre de nouvelles
expériences et en fait dans notre
développement à tous ces parle des
expériences nouvelles qu'on va
développer nos compétences motrices
qu'on va affiner notre motricité
améliorer la coordination mouvement et
petit à petit ça va se généraliser dans
l'est dans la vie quotidienne en fait
dans des gestes de la vie quotidienne
ont des enfants qui vont avoir un petit
peu des troubles de l'équilibré dans la
marche dans la course et ça va aussi les
aider petit à petit être plus à l'aise
dans leur corps
marcel couture dessous les intimes
l'école de cirque est assisté par
l'équipe de l'ump elle a dû faire
connaissance avec le handicap même si
dans le fond le principe pour eux est le
même ils ont pour habitude de faire du
cas par cas pour moi ma méthode
éducative ne changent pas d'avis qu des
enfants dits normaux pas un handicapé
quoi
c'est le même principe sauf que ben
voilà il faut prendre son temps avoir
plusieurs moyens de remédiation avoir
des techniques de remédiation voilà
trente son temps expliqué et réexpliqué
faire du cas par cas mais dans
l'éducation normal c'est comme sa fin
pour moi ça devrait être comme ça d
enseigner aux enfants porteurs de
handicap est aussi un moyen d'enrichir
leurs compétences ça nous a beaucoup
apporté aussi dans notre méthode
éducative
justement est dans notre façon de voir
le cirque dans notre façon c'est
d'aborder l'activité dans les méthodes
de remédiation qu'on a dû rechercher
pour justement arrivés à leur faire
exécuter différentes activités qui
peuvent nous servir aussi après à côté
en dehors d'eux
de leur groupe il est temps de rentrer à
l'ump après une matinée sportive et
ludique les enfants prennent un repas
ils reprendront leur activité dans
l'après midi mais d'abord une petite
interview
à rien
lorena
mais le des
mois
oui
ça continue
le cirque donne le sourire aux enfants
sortir de l'établissement s'ouvrir vers
l'extérieur pour les professionnels de
l'ump c'est aussi une occasion
d'enrichir leurs pratiques estimant moi
ça me permet d'affiner mes observations
dans le travail que je vais propose
derrière ça me permet aussi de prendre
de prendre des idées de quand je vois
moi y'a des fois des enfants je vais
bloqué sur je saurai plus comment les
aider ou il ya des gestes voilà qui ont
vraiment compliqué donc on réfléchit
ensemble et parlons par moments je me
rends compte qu'on cirque maintien il a
trouvé cette technique ça marche bien où
je vais pouvoir la reprendre en séance
c'est vraiment un travail
de collaboration après nous on a la
spécificité la psychomotricité qui va
nous permettre de faire un travail plus
approfondi de
rééducation de thérapie on va vraiment
rentrés dans la cette activité de cirque
permet les changes les professionnels de
l'ump et du cirque partage des
informations et des compétences et
avancer ensemble un partenariat qui
profite à tous et surtout aux enfants de
l'iem purement un partenariat très
important et
l'idée est partie d'une passion commune
pour les arts avec mon collègue
guillaume et donc on s'est dit pourquoi
pas le proposer et c'est là qu'on a pris
contact avec l'école du cirque et parce
que ça nous permet de travailler
vraiment énormément de choses que ce
soit de leur jolie des émotions du
ressenti
qui les enfants qui pour un exemple nous
on était très contents lorsqu'un enfant
pour la première fois a exprimé
l'émotion de peur alors comme dans la
vie quotidienne ils l'expriment pas on
se posait la question s'il avait selon
le ressenti donc c'est les choses
quelque chose comme ça ce qui peut
paraître banale qui sont très
importantes qui permettent la
construction de l'enfant son devenir
ne
on ne sait pas